"Dear Harvard" plays
Seniors!
This is your day.
"Dear Harvard" keeps playing
(new speaker) class of two thousand nine
are you guys nervous?
I am.
anxiety appears
each time I hear/ numbers of fear
economic statistics
about waste that's ballistic/about haste
that is in no way ecological. But what are we supposed
to do?
(new speaker) we are most intelligent
accomplished
and unemployed class
to ever graduate from Harvard.
Hahvahd.  Far from delivering the limitless success we
dreamt it would
seems sometimes (switch speaker) ... only doubts about whether we might in fact be the
admissions mistake
(new speaker) if i could trade places with you
and go back to being twenty one years of
age I would do it in a second.
i would take on the challenges, i would take
on the ups the downs
and heartaches that you will undoubtedly
face in these coming years i would try
in some small way (song "lean on me" starts)
(times in our lives)
you are
... the best and the brightest
(we all have pain, we all have sorrow)
And I know you will make us proud
(if we are wise, we know that there's)
(always tomorrow)
(lean on me)
(when you're not stong)
(And I'll be your friend)
(I'll help you carry on)
(for it won't)
(be long)
('till I'm gonna need somebody to lean on)
We are
0:02:27.799,0:02:32.859
an amazing class and we should always be always be able to count on and call on each other. When we walk tomorrow
Let us all think of the real meaning of the
word, "commencement"
It is a beginning.
Let us call on each other throughout our lives leaning when we must and providing
shoulder when we can
never again will there be another class of two thousand and nine so let's make
the most of it.